and let's play the sicilian
let's play the sicilian alert me now
it's f4
so f4 is a line and the way to respond
correctly to the move f4 is to open up
the center immediately with the move d5
[Music]
and the rationale behind that is we
already know that a 4 is quite a
weakening move
now how should we respond to the movie
five and i'll disable the alerts just
for now
how should we respond to e5 what is the
drawback of this move
what what square does it allow one of
our pieces now to access
so knight c6 of course is normal but but
i want a specific square that now is
accessible to one of our pieces
yeah right that's the f5 square so we
will go knight c6 but
in on the next move well actually and
this is why flexibility is where bishop
g4 would also be good
but let's get our bishop to f5 because
that's kind of what i promised
nice little you know hole in the wall
italian because
cuisine you know good spot i don't know
why i said that but
f5 is a good square okay this guy just
disconnected uh this move was so
powerful he reconnected now
he wants to go d4 and link up his
central pawns can we prevent that
can we prevent the move d4 in
in in some way yeah we can play d4
ourselves
and guess what because he's played f4
rather than develop to peace
we can afford to take this kind of
liberty a lot of people are asking how
do you know when to violate
opening principles and when to push a
lot of pawns well the reason the thing
is
he's violating principles so we can
afford to take some liberties
now let's develop our pieces let's go e6
to potentially open up the square for
the bishop
now we have an interesting situation we
have an interesting situation where
if we develop the bishop to e7 the
knight will have nowhere to go
develop the knight to e7 the bishop will
have nowhere to go how do we solve that
problem
we solved that problem by moving one of
these pieces twice
does anybody want to offer any sherlock
holmes
types in the chow and offer solution to
this problem that we have pro tishka
thank you for the tier one
where should we keep well fianchetto i
will explain why it's bad
fianchetto is actually bad because the
bishop will basically be biting on
granite on g7
exactly knight d7 knight t5 or knight to
g6
both moves are good knight d5 is better
because it's centralized and if he goes
c4
that knight can stick itself on e3
forcing him to give up a very important
bishop
and in turn that's going to open up
another outpost the d4 outpost for r9
that's if he plays c4
so zen0 314 another prime sub thank you
now we're going to develop our bishop
yep let's go to e3
take stakes and now this knight okay
can we go knight d4 does knight d4
blunder the pawn on e3
and for the record even sacrificing this
pawn would be worth it given the squares
that we get but can we go knight d4
nope why not because we have knight c2
and that's why it's bad to have an
undeveloped queen side
because this kind of stuff happens when
you don't develop one side of the board
and you weaken a lot of squares
okay he goes knight c3 instead he tries
to keep the tension what should we do
here
how should we how should we resolve this
entire situation now first of all a
non-stupid idea would be to just develop
our pieces and i mentioned this right
keeping the tension because he still
cannot take on e3 due to knight c2
but we can also make a far more
concrete approach to the position by
winning material how can we do that
how can we win material here with black
identifying his weakness on d3
bishop takes d3 is impossible but what
can we do first
we can of course we can simply take the
bishop
and it's very it's going to be very
important to take with a queen if we
think with a bishop here
he can take e3 and then he can quickly
put a rook under him so this not only
wins the pawn
but this kills the coordination of his
pieces thank you for the knight
which he just blundered and the queen is
perfectly safe because we put a bishop
on f5
okay now how do we actually how do we
proceed here well we
there's several ways we can play what
what's the simplest move
do we actually need to really do
anything here uh the answer is obviously
no that's a
rhetorical question so what would be the
most zen move ever
we could check on f2 but what would be
the most zen move ever
there should be seven yeah i just want
to show you guys that this kind of in
your face play
just develop your pieces no need to for
anything fancy just develop he's not
threatening anything we have the uh
that's right castle i kind of
allowed this but uh that's not scary at
all we could just defend the bishop
now well we have a choice we can give a
check
um and let's actually do that because
the queen always has an
evacuation route via vsc2
and it's going to be very important here
remember what i always say when you're
up a lot of material
do not cling to individual pawns
i know a lot of you want to play e2 but
e2 is actually a dangerous move because
he can potentially try to win the spawn
and the queen could get trapped on f2
so instead e as rosev very good i'm just
gonna go rook fda
i'm gonna say all right take my pawn be
my guest
but once he takes the pawn we're just
going to double on the d file
and we're basically just going to crush
him down that file we don't need this
pawn anymore it's served its purpose
it's
outlived its time now should we trade
queens here we can
we can also play queen takes p2 let's
trade queens in the interest of
simplicity because we already have our
rooks poised to get onto the d
file let's stop him from going g4
you can see that i'm stopping and time
to infiltrate with rook t3
and now uh there's many ways of winning
this position by the way it's a good
idea to fix
his king side pawns so he never can play
g4 due to a non-passant
and now we can win the game again in
several different ways let's see what he
does
he while he disconnected he seems to
having you having internet problems
yeah rook c3 c2 is an idea that i had in
mind we can try to relocate one of the
rooks to the second rank
and we can try to put the other rook on
d3 and then a lot of tactics will emerge
okay he disconnects but he's already
completely lost
um so
yeah so after g4 we would take on f3 but
like i'm talking about in the future if
this rook ever moves away we would also
stop
him from going g4 so a very simple game
we can go over it quickly
so by the way if they take on d5 here
a good idea is to go knight to f6 trying
to take the pawn on your own terms
and this is actually a gambit because
how can white defend the d5 pawn
yeah i'll answer all questions in
sequence so we will go over the game if
you have a question about the end game
please wait
until we are at that stage of the
analysis to ask the question to keep the
flow
now for extra credit uh how
what should black do here what should
black do here and and
after this correct move is stated yes e6
can somebody explain to me why it is
that black has
not only full compensation for the pawn
but black is probably actually
better in this position why is that
there's
three reasons three very specific
reasons that can be identified here
number one is development we have a lot
more developments
number two number two that development
is the sort of obvious pawn structure
but
i want you guys to be more specific yes
number two is the weakness on f4 right
white has pushed his pawn out to f4
which means that if he castles king's
side he will never be completely safe
well what is the third thing yeah so the
second thing is that he's created all
these weaknesses yeah
and uh oh oh dramaali mao
pointing out the correct third factor
which is the d4 square this is a
humongous outpost for the knight
you can imagine that if a knight lands
on d4 oh that's a
juicy juicy central square okay
and by the way when i say that a couple
of you might be thinking well wait a
second
how are we going to get a knight on d4
when there is a white knight on f3
but the point isn't that we will get the
knight on d4 immediately
uh the point is that this will always be
hanging over white like the sword of
damocles the knight ever
is gone from f3 or if it's eliminated
then the knight on d4 will be basically
unassailable
and i can show you guys many examples of
games that go like this where you weaken
a square
thinking that ah it's fine i have a
piece guarding that square eventually
that piece is eliminated
and uh there is hell to pay as a
consequence
and to give you guys a very quick very
promise very very quick example is a
detour
and i like doing this i think it helps
people remember i had
i had a painful experience like this one
time
exactly like this where i made this kind
of misjudgment
thinking that uh one of the the squares
i weakened is perfectly well defended by
one of my pieces but um
yeah so there we go
let me just switch scenes one second and
i have to switch to the chess-based
scene
all right
yeah and i'll i'll continue the game
after that
yeah so uh this position
was from one of my games from 2009
against the grand master
what is the weak square in this position
that that is in question
and how should white go about occupying
that weak square
white to play and
okay d5 is of course the key weakness
what should white do here
well d6 is a weak pawn but whoops no
so what should i do should white
immediately put a knight on d5 or should
white do something first
so actually no knight d5 is not correct
bishop g5 is correct
and the reason that knight d5 is not
correct is because
if you think about it what's going to
happen in the end
is that a rook is going to get to d5 but
what piece does white actually want on
d5 he probably wants a knight on d5
uh here how can black go about
dislodging this rook from d5
that's by the way why knights are better
um
outpost occupiers than rooks because
rooks and queens are easy to kick away
like knight before exactly so what my
opponent does
is go bishop g5 and then he takes the
knight
and then he comes back to c3 and
knight d5 now it is true i just said
that knights are the best outpost
occupiers but this is an exception
why is this an exception for the very
simple reason
first of all the rook is unassailable
but guess what he does
guess what he does boom for extra credit
does anyone want to tell me where this
night is going
where is the where the hell is this
knight eventually going
look at this where this thing where is
this thing going
boom boom boom
and like clockwork boom
look at the beauty beautiful position
all of his pieces come into the game
and he gets an unassailable not on d5
many many moves after that weak
uh square was first created so that's
the the power
and the danger of creating an outpost
like this because it can it can define
the whole game
okay and why is this knight so good
because it's visually i mean
look at it it's dominating over the
whole board and my opponent eventually
won
so this was a very good lesson uh for me
to
to to be very careful about how i go
about
uh managing my weaknesses and it's okay
to create weaknesses if
you have counterbalancing factors chess
is a game of tit for tat
as i always say uh but weak squares in
particular in the center of the board
that can be occupied with knights
be very careful about that okay
back to the speed run so that's the
reason why this sacrifice is kind of
fine from a general perspective so our
opponent played e5 which is fine
bishop f5 this is normal developing now
d4 is
the key move uh we could have gone here
but then we would have allowed him to go
d4 actually this is a good position for
black
this is like a good french if you know
what the french looks like
and and comparison is often a good way
to evaluate positions by the way
this is i think a point that some people
miss you can often make a lot of sense
of a position by comparing it
this is the main line of the french
advance now
literally we can take this position and
compare it
side by side to well to this position
the bishop has jumped over the pawn on
e6 which is a really good thing
french is a solid opening so this by
definition
like by a transitive property has to be
at least quite a bit better than the
french
and but still we decided to prevent him
from doing that
and now of course we solve the problem
of insufficient space by getting the
knight to the center
and then we get it to e3 vacating the d4
square for the other knight which we
occupy
win the pawn take the free knight
develop our pieces
give up the pawn for the greater good
double rooks infiltrate stop his king
side threats and win the game
so very simple methodical and the key
thing to remember when converting the
advantage
do not hesitate to go up a pawn or two
for sort of the greater good
okay any questions
why not bishop takes h3 and if you're
indicating a move that i didn't play
try to be specific try to be
uh try to be specific about where
well fantastic fan that's a too general
of a question
for whiter for black and i basically
if you want to look at my what i play in
the speed run like i try to tailor the
openings to what i would recommend to
that level
okay let's go on
isn't that central night worth more than
his undeveloped bishop that you trade
that's a great question by second hanska
um and yes in a strict sense you're
right
this knight is is is better place than
the bishop but
if you think about what happens as a
consequence of this trade
we get a square that's again worth its
weight in gold
so you do make a small positional
concession giving up a better
piece in a strict sense but in return
you get
something that that is is far a far
greater value
than the relative superiority of the
night over the bishop
um yes so even if queen c1 won a pawn i
would still have probably gone there
because again
we would get this massive potential
outpost
okay every segment will be on youtube
virtually every segment will be on
youtube guys
it will also be in my twitch vods so
worry not okay so let's go for another
sicilian
uh and i want to keep things moving
along uh so i'm sorry if i didn't get to
people's questions
now bishop c4 how do we usually meet
this move uh
as a review from our earlier games we
don't see this move that often anymore
it's it's more common at like a 1200
1300 level
yeah so we want to go e6 at some point
let's first develop our knight
but then we want to go e6 to blunt the
bishop and
and we can go d5 we don't have to though
we can actually develop with knight f6
this is the best move actually
and uh to some people this might okay
now we have a really cool idea
um what is this really cool idea i i've
mentioned it in other contexts before
like it exists in other types of
positions but
uh yeah man we got some people on fire
here
knight takes e4 bingo knight takes c4
and then d5
what makes this good is that it it
eliminates white's control over the
center
okay he doesn't take so let's just go d5
anyway but if he would have taken the
knight we go d5
eliminating his control over the center
and taking out his
kind of important light squared bishop
so
now we're up upon we can simply um
continue our development in a sort of
conventional fashion we can first unpin
ourselves with bishop d7
thank you glad to hear that major first
uh
should we take the night and don't say
no just because i ask a question
i'm i i know that's like the high school
thing to do
uh and i'm used to that from like my own
tests yes we should
because we [ __ ] this bond structure
why not trades are good
let's just develop the other bishop
again is this passive in a strict sense
kind of but we're up upon we have a huge
center
and so again remember not every one of
your pieces has to be
conquering the you know fringes of the
roman empire at any moment okay okay
sephora is a very good move
uh which pawn should we take or should
we even take
a pawn yeah so what we what we want to
try to do here
how should i put it is is is take the
sting out of what's going on in the
center we want to be careful about
opening up the e file before we've
castled
thank you a hardest hussein so we
actually want to play knight takes d4
and i'll explain after the game
exactly why knight takes d4
uh is the best capture versus all the
other captures i'll explain it blow by
blow
and he also disconnected man we are
dealing with
some disconnectors today
one of the keys to understanding knight
64 is to understand that if
takes takes takes we have what move at
the end of the line and it's already
been mentioned
but i want a couple of you to point out
now this move wow looks like he's
overwhelmed by this
what is the move yeah bishop f6 right
and and you skewer the queen to the rook
winning the rook
right and he yep another disconnect wow
these are some short games
so yeah so basically e6
knight f6 now what about e5
in this position uh e5 looks a little
bit nasty but we can immediately target
the pawn with knight g4
and we can actually go d6 breaking up
the spawn forcing it to
to take and we have a perfectly good
position for black
where should this bishop go where where
should the c8 bishop
be developed eventually either now or
in the future yeah b7 of course we
should fianchetto it
this is a great idea to fianchetto the
bishop you actually have horowitz
bishops that's what they're called
because they're both sort of angling at
the king so
you should take the clue from the other
bishop like their pieces should
cooperate
and that's the reason why e5 is not
dangerous
d5 is also fine but the problem is he
doesn't have to on passant here and your
knight could get
like stuck on h6 potentially okay
um and by the way white has to go rookie
one because
this would blunder upon so ricky won
tite takes c4
that's the key move d5 here would be not
as effective because after e takes d5 we
would not be able to capture
with the pawn due to the pin so
if rook takes uh we go d5
and we we pin and and you guys are are
very much familiar with uh
with this idea what should white do here
like to and remember that when you're
losing a piece especially if you've
blundered or
you're in the middle of some sort of
tactical operation
uh you want to give that piece up for
the maximum amount of material so bishop
d5
queen d5 knight c3 defending attacking
but i simply dropped my queen back
black's got the two bishops
black's got better central control than
white and uh eventually this bishop from
c8 is going to be fianchettoed
and remember we've eliminated white's
light squad bishop so it's going to be
completely uncontested
which is a really good thing when you're
fianchetto to the long diagonal facing
the can
hopefully that makes sense the position
is still equal but
it's a pleasant kind of equal so he goes
d4 we go d5
now the key moment in the game
there's no science to understanding the
pawn square
we just have to consider all of the
captures and
weigh their pros and cons dtx4
i didn't like for a very specific reason
and what i don't like about this is that
if this e pawn disappears from e6 he's
gonna have a direct line to my king
i don't really like that situation so he
can go d5
which is another pawn sacrifice but you
can you guys appreciate that this is a
little bit nasty right i mean he's got
the pressure
sure i can castle but now heaphy and
keto is the bishop and
you know how this bishop kind of stares
down my g7 pawn
in short white's pieces here are very
active and i don't like a situation
where yeah even at the cost of two pawns
uh there's such a disparity in piece
activity
so that capture was ruled out now this
one
he plays c takes d5 and it's exactly the
same thing
the e file has gotten opened he can
actually pile up on it with queen e2
and i'm having a hard time castling so
that was out of the question
now what about not reacting at all this
would be my second choice
the issue with this is now he takes a
bunch of times and he isolates the pawn
on d5
right now the pawn on d5 is super weak
if i play bishop c5
then queen takes d5 and he restores
material equality we actually get a
similar scenario
as in the the d-take c4 line and so for
that reason
knight takes d4 is the best what this
actually does is it prevents c takes d5
because now this bishop is going to be
hanging
which was not the case previously and if
he tries to remedy the problem of the
bishop by first taking
then c takes d5 allows queen takes d5
and once again queen takes d4 allows
bishop f6
skill wearing the queen to the rock and
instead he disconnected but uh already
white isn't
in very big very big trouble does that
make sense
hopefully i was at least semi
you know coherent and explaining the
various captures and
here's the concluding point i'll make
before we move on to the next game
which is that there are certain
positions
where not every single chess move has
verbal logic behind it sometimes you
just have to freaking get your hands
dirty
and look at the moves okay there's no
like inherent reason why knight d4
is the move uh it's just that the other
moves are bad
and there's a reason that the other why
the others are bad
uh but you just have to calculate uh and
and uh it's you can't always talk your
way into the correct move
you usually in fact the higher rated you
get
the less you talk to yourself during the
game and the more you calculate
so at my level the
logic behind moves is is commonplace to
everybody like all gms have a baseline
level of knowledge and you're not going
to beat anybody by
out logicking them if that makes sense
at the gm level
so that's why calculation becomes so
incredibly crucial although it's crucial
at all levels
it's particularly indispensable at the
grand master level because
a marginal superiority over someone else
in terms of your visualization your
ability to calculate
can result in you know exponential
uh improvements in in your games because
that's
such a high stakes uh area of the game
okay so let me put it this way
at the gm level everybody knows how to
make layups so
um you're you're sort of practicing your
three-pointer
and at other levels and i don't mean
this in a condescending way
uh if you shoot layups or free throws
really really well you can get a huge
edge over somebody but
at a certain point everybody is a 90
free throw shooter
so that's why other things become
important